so we talk about wealth inequality all
the time and everyone talks about the 1%
that it's about the 1% but as I've
mentioned many times it really isn't the
1 percent because the 1% in America
sometimes depending on what figures
you're looking at it could be around
300,000 that you're making a year may be
around 500,000 something like that not
obscenely obscenely rich so an
interesting new study came out at
Berkeley University that it really is
about the point one percent that's the
crazy number so we've got a graph here
that's gonna explain a little bit more
so right now in the late 1920s the
bottom 90% held just 16% of America's
wealth considerably less than held by
the top 0.1% which controlled about 25
percent so you can see that at the
beginning of that chart on the left
right there from the beginning of the
depression until well after the Second
World War the middle class share of the
total wealth rose steadily so the
numbers started separating that was good
great for the middle class good for the
economy but then those trends have now
reversed and just like the 1920s the top
point one percent hold 22 percent of
America's well almost the same share as
the bottom 90 percent of the population
and that's what you can see all the way
to the right on that that they basically
have exactly the same amount the one the
point one percenter is not the one
percenters the point one percenters have
the same amount of well as the as the
bottom 90% by the way the top one
percent or the top point one percent I
should say consists of a hundred sixty
thousand families and they average worth
it's about seventy three million so is
the one percent thing it just sounds
good right like is that sort of it just
sounds more romantic right like you know
sometimes you just need like a bumper
sticker to get things going and if they
had said well it's the point one percent
that would have confused people so
sometimes you just go is the one percent
and that's just enough is that is this
partly just messaging
I mean the point one person is
astonishing right that's to anyone who
can do basic math is actually more more
crazy and more romantic almost that's
like so so stark the inequality that's
interesting so really by putting it in
there they could have drove the home the
point home even more yeah I mean I sort
of like to take the opportunity to shout
out to my hometown in Seattle which just
raised the minimum wage to fifteen
percent yeah and having a conversation
fifteen dollars I think it's I mean I
think that's a huge step in the right
direction for sort of writing this wrong
that exists right now I mean anyone who
sort of thinks that that's gonna be a
terrible strategy has a really
short-sighted view of how the economy
works and putting money in the pockets
of the people who were at sort of the
lower end of that graph is really the
best sustainable way because you're
gonna end up and you know they're gonna
have contributing to the economy better
and those companies that had to it maybe
initially lay off some workers because
of the minimum wage hike are gonna be
able to hire them again so you're saying
you don't believe in trickle-down
economics that if we could just give
rich people more money they'd give more
little jobs to the little people you
just don't buy that ya know I can't even
ah mcc's but I believe that everyone
should participate in Tribute
trickle-down economics not just the
point one percent yeah I don't begrudge
these people success I really don't and
this is what America is all about I
think everyone should have the
opportunity to get but so what do we do
what what's like a really see every time
we talk about this then everyone just so
it's just easy to hate rich people you
know I mean it's just so easy to do it
so what is the solution and like should
it be like after 50 million your tax
that's seventy five percent if you get
making 50 million you're doing pretty
well I know in the comments people are
gonna be hating me for that even but
like is is there some way to make a tax
system that actually is fair and of
course then they'll still they'll send
the money the Cayman Islands and all
that but within
a conversation that we can have in four
minutes like is there anything we can do
to sort of wrangle this thing in a
sensible way simple tax yeah do you
think that's how it should be I don't
know about 50 million definitionally
regressive right I don't know I mean I
think that it's probably not gonna be an
attack system or in the non profit
system that we figure it out it really
is gonna be in legislation that is that
is meant to just compensate people
better for the work that they're doing
but is there any chance that legislation
could actually happen cuz don't aren't
these the guys that buy the politicians
and money in politics like why would the
politicians go against their donors and
am at ball game that we talk about
constants also like why would you
participate in the giving pledge then
right I mean like there there are people
who got there and who recognized that
they got there because of you know not
just sort of ruthless business skill but
also like really hard-working people
that they built their company on and so
and recognize that the inequality is
created dramatically by the the
legislative system and are sort of the
giving pledges attempt to sort of bypass
that I think as well yeah through
donations to nonprofits or whatever it
might be but um no I think that I think
that personally a minimum wage hike is a
good first step in stone and I think
that there's a lot of a lot of other
really interesting approaches you know
education and all of that so that people
can feel better about paying a minimum a
higher minimum wage but like I've
questioned is there anything that you
guys would do for a straight week actual
labor at $15 an hour is there any I mean
I've done jobs for less than $15 an hour
well right now in your life would you
you know go and and not just because you
see it as like a vacation for yeah sort
of sitting here but like you could
actually see yourself doing for a month
or a year like when you put yourself
right those in their shoes or in the
shoes of someone who is working at what
used to be an 8 dollar minimum wage
that's not $15 it's like oh yeah no like
that's not enough to live on and that's
not a great existence right so maybe
their taxes should be lower people don't
like that argument they're like it's
it's a big [ __ ] is there anything
we can do to get America back on track
because it seems to me that if if I was
in the point
1% it's in your own vested interest to
have the rest of the people happy
because then they don't come at you with
pitchforks but it seems to me we're like
just angling this to the pitchfork
things you know you mean but it's hard
to crawl over a gated community carrying
a pitchfork that is a good point but the
purge and it's possible so if you don't
want the purge you should at least think
about maybe some ways that we can get
those those things to separate a little
bit and let's get the middle class back
on track and subscribe right down below